[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 26 novembre voici les
titres de cette édition est le début de
la trente cinquième campagne d'hiver des
restos du coeur c'est jusqu'au 15 mars
l'an passé 1,8 millions de repas ont été
distribués dans les yvelines l'antenne
départementale qui s'attend à une hausse
des bénéficiaires tout en accusant dans
le même temps une baisse du nombre des
bénévoles
l'estaca accueillait aujourd'hui le pari
serait john aux reason cyber la
conférence francilienne sur la
cybersécurité en présence des principaux
acteurs
objectif valoriser le secteur et faire
connaître les initiatives régionales en
la matière et une grande soirée dédiée
au dubstep elle se déroulera le 7
décembre au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'événement
célèbrera les 10 ans du label never say
die avec mon plateau bernard bailly
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable du site
des restos du coeur à la verrière on
vous reçoit ce soir bien sûr puisque
s'ouvre aujourd'hui est la trente
cinquième campagne d'hiver des restos du
coeur dans les yvelines les entrepôts
ont déjà rempli les stocks de produits
pour les redistribuer dans les 26
centres du territoire le nombre de
bénéficiaires devrait encore augmenter
cette année au contraire des bénévoles
qui peine à se renouveler reportage aux
clayes-sous-bois de mathilde denis
jacques commence sa journée à 6h30 à
l'entrepôt des restos du coeur aux
clayes-sous-bois depuis douze ans il a
les mêmes rituels préparer les commandes
les emballer et les charger mais depuis
quelques temps le manque d'effectifs se
fait de plus en plus ressentir
les années passent si vous voulez hier
25 kg c'était rigolo
aujourd'hui 25 kg on arrive tous dans
les 70 ans passés bon 25 kg deviennent
très très lourd et on demande
à chacun bon attention on fait attention
on fait attention à sif attention à ça
et on essaie d'aller de l'avant mais il
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui s'il nous manque
une personne
c'est un problème dans les yvelines 1200
bénévoles travaillent chaque jour dans
les 26 centres pour distribuer les
denrées alimentaires élu depuis
septembre le nouveau président
s'inquiète du peu d'intérêt que porte la
jeunesse pour l'association
on a de moins en moins de candidatures
hélas on a quand même un certain nombre
de bénévoles qui nous quitte pour des
raisons tout à fait normal c'est qu'ils
ont abandonnée de temps qu'ils aspirent
à voir un petit peu à peu plus de
tranquillité
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
problème dont souffrent avant tout les
restos du coeur et le réseau associatif
c'est un manque de bénévoles
un appel à l'aide de l'association pour
combler le manque d'effectifs
malgré le besoin de bénévoles les
livraisons arriveront à temps à trappes
sincère bois d'arcy et tous les autres
centres des restos du coeur dans les
yvelines est également la verrière où un
centre des restos du coeur est également
situé bernard bailly vous en êtes le
responsable
le constat du manque de bénévoles qui
est fait au niveau départemental est ce
que vous le faites aussi sur le site de
la verrière est ce que il manque
aujourd'hui ses bénévoles
non on peut pas dire ça on ne fait pas
le constat à cette année mais on l'a
fait dans les années précédentes on
considère aujourd'hui qu'on est
correctement dimensionné on a trente
bénévoles permanents et pas vous dire ce
qui se passait il ya encore trois ans et
avec quinze bénévoles de lire deux fois
moins et probablement autant de familles
accueillir vous avez réussi à attirer
des bénévoles handicap pour affronter la
saison d'hiver
cette année oui on a le nombre
nécessaire et suffisant maintenant et
toutes les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenues
j'allais dire on fera jamais trop
comment on peut l'expliquer à votre avis
qui est une crise de la vocation
peut-être auprès des jeunes des jeunes
qui ont du mal à s'engager est ce que
quel est le constat que vous voudrez
c'est le constat qu'on dresse
effectivement c'est que 80% des
bénévoles sont des retraités donc plus
de 60 65 ans on a assez peu de jeunes il
faut dire que quand on est jeune c'est
pas facile là à gérer un emploi du temps
qui peut être combiné avec des études
avec du travail la recherche d'emploi
alors qu'un traité si je puis dire c'est
une valeur sûre
pas mal de disponibilité bien que les
retraitres et prennent aussi des
vacances les retraités ont des
petits-enfants à garder n'est un tt
ondes et santé qui sont pas toujours les
meilleurs surtout vers la fin donc pour
un jeune oui ça peut être compliqué on a
eu des jeunes ou qui sont venus du
département sur deux nous aider il est
en recherche d'emploi sont restées assez
peu de temps tant mieux pour eux mais je
dirais presque le temps de déformer paix
ils sont partis ils vous parlez de 30
bénévoles donc sur le site de la
verrière qui assure du coup le bon
fonctionnement de ce site quel rythme
d'ouvertures quel est le rythme
d'ouverture pendant cette campagne
d'hiver notre activité se répartit en 3
1 3 période on a le lundi on a une
équipe dédiée à l'approvisionnement
celeron réceptionne les denrées et on
on range les stops et on à challandes
les étagères et puis on est ouvert le
mardi matin et le jeudi matin pour la
distribution on essaie d'avoir 50 % des
personnes accueillies sur chaque demi
journée c'est pas facile et donc les
bénévoles se répartissent pour ceux qui
participent à la distribution sur ces
deux demi journées donc trente bénévoles
vous serez assez pour cette saison ça
veut dire vous l'abordez plutôt
sereinement cette 35ème campagne plutôt
sereinement oui comme j'étais tout à
l'heure par rapport à des années qu'ils
sont pas si lointaine plutôt sereinement
du tout seulement 1,8 millions de repas
distribués l'an passé dans les yvelines
dans les 26 centres yvelinois des restos
du coeur treize mille personnes environ
ont été accueillis sur le site de la
verrière environ sait combien de repas
sont combien de repas qui ont été
distribués l'an passé l'été dernier la
période la plus récente 22000 à peu près
22 mille repas sur huit mois sachant
qu'on va à peu près la même chose sur 4
mois parce qu'on accueille plus de monde
en hiver
combien de personnes nous on a inscrit
sept étaient 126 famille cent vingt-six
familles ce qui fait un peu moins de 285
adultes à peu près et quelques enfants
on n'a pas beaucoup d'enfants il ya des
centres qui sont qui ont beaucoup plus
d'enfants de bébés plus tôt ils ont même
spécialisés ya deux centres spécialisés
dans l'accueil des bébés
nous on a plutôt des personnes seules ou
des parents isolés
est ce qu'au fil des saisons la tendance
ceux des bénéficiaires est plutôt à la
hausse et ce qu'ils ont tendance à
augmenter
c'est chez nous chez nous on est
toujours à peu près dans les mêmes zones
c'est-à-dire cent vingt 120 familles à
peu près plus souvent l'été ou l'hiver
d'ailleurs même si les critères d'accès
en été sont un peu différents ceux
d'hiver parce qu'on a moins de choses à
distribuer donc on est obligé de
restreindre un peu l'accès en était cela
étant on arrive quand même à des pour la
verrière d'une petite commune des
yvelines
on arrive quand même avoir un nombre de
participants c'est je veux dire c'est
élevé vous avez raison aussi parlé de la
campagne des terrains puisqu'il ya la
campagne d'hiver qui est très connu au
parlement de la campagne d'été mais
effectivement elle existe aussi au sein
de ces restos du coeur si on regarde les
chiffres au niveau national vous évoquez
le profil des bénéficiaires au niveau
national et les constater que plus de la
moitié des bénéficiaires des restos du
coeur 51 % exactement aux moins de 26
ans est ce qu'il ya aussi de plus en
plus de jeunes parmi ces bénéficiaires à
la verrière en a des jeunes pas à ce
niveau là on a des jeunes effectivement
des jeunes là il se fait que très
récemment on a accueilli six mineurs qui
provenaient de l'afrique subsaharienne
six mineurs isolés par définition et
puis on a quelques jeunes aussi mais
c'est pas la caractéristique de du
centre on a beaucoup de mamans avec
enfants isolés on a des sans abri
heureusement et puis on a des personnes
qui j'allais dire qu'il passe chez nous
sans s'arrêter très longtemps parce que
elles sont à la verrière une semaine et
puis la semaine suivante elles seront
ailleurs dans le département ou dans des
départements limitrophes et qui ont pu
donc avoir cette aide importante des
restos du coeur
dans ce contexte beaucoup peut-être par
fierté parce qu'ils n'osent pas ne
pousse pas la porte des restos du coeur
qui peut venir aux restos du coeur
par définition tout le monde enfin tous
ceux qui ont besoin bien évidemment
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile dans la
constater à plusieurs après c'est pas
facile parce qu'on ne l'a dit de pousser
la porte des restos des fois faut un peu
de courage surtout quand tu tournes
habite dans l'ensemble par exemple
on est implantée à la verrière les
résidents très proche du centre des
restos parfois un peu de mal a
effectivement à venir chez nous mais
tout le monde peut venir dès lors qu' on
est dans le besoin dès lors qu'on a
besoin d' aides alimentaires
essentiellement vestimentaires et qu'on
la célèbre chanson dis qu'on peut y
trouver un peu de pain et de chaleur
c'est des denrées alimentaires c'est oui
on y trouve un peu plus que du des
produits de première nécessité on y
trouve un peu plus que du pain on essaie
de donner aux gens de quoi constituer un
repas équilibré avec des protides avec
des légumes avec des produits laitiers
et des desserts et puis au delà ont
fourni dans la mesure du possible quand
on en a des éléments de produits
d'hygiène par exemple ou des compléments
alimentaires comme l'huile dessus ou ou
la farine riz mais on trouve aussi
beaucoup de chaleur parce que les
bénévoles très largement très
massivement sont des gens chaleureux et
qui savent accueillir les gens qui
justement pousse la porte chine merci
bernard banide est revenu sur ce plateau
responsable du centre de là derrière des
restos du coeur 26 130 ou dans le
département je le rappelle toutes les
informations sur ces sites sur le site
internet de l'antenne départementale des
restos du coeur un site internet sur
lequel on peut également donner aux
restos du coeur
merci beaucoup merci dans l'actualité du
jour l'université paris saclay dont fait
partie lui vs qu à la rencontre des
étudiants et citoyens l'établissement a
lancé aujourd'hui à guyancourt un cycle
de performance et des changes dans
l'espace public l'objectif mieux
connaître les attentes autour de
l'université une question posée aux
participants et vous apprenez vous de
nouvelles choses justement une chose
originale était proposé notamment une
récolte des huîtres dans le bassin marta
pan explications au micro de marylène
yapi chinon qui ne rend compte que très
improbable en fait on propose d'avoir de
rencontrer des personnes qui récolte des
huîtres dans l'espace public dans les
égouts est ici dans le bassin marta pan
et
de ces de ces échanges la en fait on
introduit une réflexion sur qu'est-ce
qui est vrai qu est ce qui n'est pas
vrai commence en forme et on pose une
question à l'ensemble des personnes qui
sont là avec la question c est vous ou
apprenez vous de nouvelles choses et
l'objectif c'est vraiment d'en savoir
plus sur les habitudes et d'avoir des
réponses très personnel c'est la
conférence francilienne sur la
cybersécurité le pari serait john aux
reason cybers se tenait ce mardi sur le
campus de l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux l'événement a rassemblé de
nombreux acteurs du secteur en ile de
france tous présents pour parler des
enjeux stratégiques de la cybersécurité
nicolas landry c'est un des enjeux
majeurs liés à l'évolution des
technologies la cybersécurité avec la
protection des données
une activité dans laquelle est engagé le
groupe atos un sujet importante dans son
développement de l'ordinateur quantique
sur son site des clayes-sous-bois ses
ordinateurs de ses ordinateurs
quantiques vont permettre de décrypter
des algorithmes des algorithmes
cryptographiques qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas être attaqué par des
ordinateurs classiques simplement parce
que l'ordinateur quantique accélère très
fortement les calculs atos l'un des
acteurs de la cybersécurité à saint
quentin en yvelines à côté d'airbus ou
de thales également présente des
startups comme auxi box créé en 2014
avec une croissance moyenne de 100 % par
an puis numerix une pme du territoire
engager toutes les deux dans ce secteur
notre ambition effectivement d'avoir un
système qui va permettre que les données
qui sont sauvegardés les systèmes qui
sont sauvegardés sont complètement
invisible à ces attaques et
conséquemment suite à une attaque très
rapidement en deux clics on va être
capable de redémarrer les systèmes
infectés que nous avons l'intention est
l'objectif de mettre en place une une
formation dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité et de plus loin ce sera
effectivement le management de la
cybersécurité et on commence
effectivement donc ces formations-là
notamment les fondements de la cyber
sécurité mais aussi la cryptologie d'ici
à la fin d'année
cette matinée avait un objectif c'est de
réunir toute la filière tout
l'écosystème en matière de cybersécurité
qui est une filière qui créent des
emplois qui est une filière d'avenir est
essentiel pour la souveraineté aussi
bien de notre pays ici à saint quentin
qui est notre territoire qui est un
territoire bien positionné en matière de
cybersécurité en france près de 8
entreprises sur dix sont touchés par des
cyberattaques 43 % de ces attaques
visent les petites et moyennes
entreprises
le site des yvelines est le seul en
france à construire ce véhicule
électrique l'usiné renault de flins sur
seine à produire lundi sa 200 millièmes
l'eau est de couleur noire et les
sorties des chaînes de montage à 15h10
précise plusieurs cadres de la marque au
losange ont fait le déplacement pour
l'occasion
la voiture sera livrée à un
concessionnaire d'eindhoven aux pays-bas
que ce soit en roman en bd ou pour la
jeunesse l'histoire multipliait ses
formes ce week-end pour le salon
histoire de lire à versailles plus de 50
auteurs on a répondu présent pour
rencontrer l électeur patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poker yves saint
laurent et hubert védrine ont un point
commun olrik l'ennemi de blake et
mortimer le premier perpétue le
maléfique colonel imaginé par edgar p
jacobs les seconds lui consacre une
biographie on a reconstitué le loric du
vrai dont jacob s'est inspirée et lee
après jean van hamme et d'autres
scénariste talentueux il y a continué la
piste jacobsen il ya certainement
beaucoup de correspondances
il joue avec les vérités c'est
de tout auteur tel but premier de jacobs
et 7 buts des auteurs qui reprennent la
série aujourd'hui son rôle rick est
différent de celui de jacob ce mais on
va découvrir en lisant son livre où se
situe le lien entre les deux alaric très
intéressant et des échanges et des
discussions qui anime histoire de lire
le salon versailles et accueilli plus de
170 auteurs comme l'ancien ministre
jean-pierre chevènement
j'y trouve un public cultivé amateur de
livres et c'est toujours agréable les
débats sont de bon niveau
patient parce que j'aime la france mes
passions aussi parce que la france a
beaucoup souffert et je rappelle dans
l'introduction à mon livre que je ne
suis pas née impunément en 1939
j'ai vécu l'occupation mon père était
fait prisonnier la maison de ma
grand-mère a brûlé bref pour moi
l'histoire s'est invitée très tôt dans
ma vie ce qu'on veut étoffer c'est
vraiment les rencontres pour que le
public ait davantage la possibilité de
discuter avec les auteurs et qu'on ait
des débats sur l'histoire
une cinquantaine de débats et d'échangés
était organisée existant depuis 2008 le
salon a reçu cette année plus de vingt
mille personnes
ils font partie en quelque sorte de
l'histoire les arbres qui ont parfois
plusieurs centaines d'années
l'association arbres et la région
viennent d'entériner une première liste
des arbres et ensemble remarquable
d'ile-de-france 132 en tout ont été
répertoriés 24 dans les yvelines dont le
platane de diane aux clayes sous bois à
l'image plantés il ya 500 ans il doit
son nom à son instigatrice diane de
poitiers favorite du roi henri ii est la
classification permet une meilleure
valorisation et protection de ces arbres
une dose de jeu pendant deux semaines à
saint quentin en yvelines l'élu d'ideye
se clôturait le week-end dernier avec la
nuit du jeu retour sur cet événement
avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
marylène iapichino pour clôturer ces lui
10 days le réseau des médiathèques a
sorti le grand jeu
le muguet d'accueiller une nuit
consacrée à l'amusement pour tous les
âges
le but c'est vraiment de s'amuser tous
ensemble et demain
que les médiathèques sont des lieux qui
accueillent le jeu aussi bien que des
livres et que le jeu est un produit
culturel comme l'irak alors je vais une
sorcière malines mais parfaire son jeu
d'acteur pour un jeu de rôle où sa
stratégie pour un jeu de plateau les
jeux sont faits sultan vient de battre
sa maman en fait faut isoler un peu
l'adversaire dans un coin et thuram et
le tnt be et après après tu les
renverser sur les côtés plus loin à del
se laisse prendre au jeu de cette
impressionnante structure
apparemment c'est un adhérent 3d bon on
essaie d'arriver au milieu salade après
impossible pour ceux qui se veulent plus
vieux jeu
l'association name cochaux proposait de
retomber dans des pixels pas si lointain
alors là en fait on est venu pour amener
nos enfants pour leur faire plaisir et
résultat on s'est mis devant la console
de notre adolescence et on a perdu nos
enfants on présente des anciennes
machines qui ont fait l'histoire du jeu
vidéo sous la forme de bandes de
démonstration et les bordelais
monstration c'est ce qu'on pourrait
trouver dans les magasins
quand les consoles sortais à l'époque et
fin des jeux de moore
cette année les l'udinese ont réuni plus
de 4600 personnes et après une nuit
dédiée au jeu c'est une nuits musicales
et festives qui va débarquer à saint
quentin en yvelines le vélodrome
nationale va vivre va vivre au rythme du
dubstep grande soirée au programme le
samedi 7 décembre dans l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise le nom de cet
événement ambassades l'événement fête
les 10 ans du label never say die pour
en parler d'eux invités brusque holstein
bonsoir bonsoir responsable marketing et
communication du vélodrome nationale et
salit ma mamie bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
l'un des organisateurs de l'événement on
va tout de suite d'ailleurs regardez le
teaser
[Musique]
voilà pour le teaser bruce le vélodrome
avait déjà accueilli un événement du
genre en 2017 la nuit de l'électro 4000
personnes étaient venues sur place ça
vous tenez à coeur d'organiser et
d'accueillir de nouveau ce genre
d'événement complètement sûr nous tient
à coeur de le perpétuer le spectacle
vivant donc voilà on développe mon
prospect c'est en france qu'on accueille
de la bass music le 7 décembre et on se
régale et on espère que que le public
sera au rendez vous et c'est l'occasion
de rappeler vous le dit à chaque fois
sur ce plateau que ce vélodrome
nationale n'a pas que vocation à
accueillir des événements sportifs c'est
sa vocation principale mais il ya aussi
le but de ceux ci d'être une arena
d'accueillir d'autres types d'événements
tout à fait valide rom pour le vélo
effectivement mais derrière on a une
véritable ambition et d objectif d'en
faire un pôle de référence pour les
spectacles vivants et c'est en ce sens
aussi qu on continue notre prospection
et et notre démarche cadre le public
cinq continents quatre mille personnes
pour la nuit de l'électron 2010 est là
vous vous attendez à accueillir combien
de cinq mille 5000 repousse les limites
en toute sécurité mais on repousse les
limites et on espère encore une fois que
le spectacle sera au rendez vous on en a
aucun doute alors salim cet événement se
déroulait avant tout près de paris aux
docks d'aubervilliers pourquoi
s'exporter dans la région francilienne à
dire plus profonde en tout cas en grande
couronne francilienne pourquoi le
proposer ici il ya il ya plusieurs
points mais le premier déjà c'était de
faire un événement un peu plus gros que
ce qu'on faisait déjà avant aux docks
sur le dock eiffel on était bloqué à des
mille personnes sur le dock pullman on
est bloqué à quatre mille et là on
voulait vraiment chercher une salle un
peu plus grande pour ramener un petit
peu la magie américaine ici en france et
faire des événements encore plus gros si
vous étiez obligés de refuser du monde
les autres anus bas on a en soldats août
mais c'est surtout qu'on peut pas faire
plus gros et le public d'abstrait
regarde souvent et tout le temps les
vidéos sur internet des festivals des
shows ou des gros événements qui se
passent un peu partout ailleurs surtout
aux états unis et on en manque un peu
ici donc il fallait prénom je trouve une
salle qu'ils un peu plus que 4000
personnes pour pouvoir proposer un show
comme m
d'assez grande envergure avec l'objectif
de 5000 personnes à accueillir le
dubstep qui fait partie de la grande
famille de la musique électronique des
musiques électroniques quelle est la
spécificité pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas le dubstep bas on dit que le dubstep
il est dans la famille de la belle
musique puisqu'il ya beaucoup de bayes
mais c'est un mouvement qui arrivait
dans les années 90 dans le sud de
londres
et c'était des rythmes un peu saccadé
avec un petit goût reggae un petit goût
dub avec des voix de m6 et tout
doucement bahia les machines
électroniques qui sont rentrés dedans
d'accord jusqu'à ce que en 2010 le gros
un des gros noms du dubstep qui est
skrillex en un album et là ça devient
réputation internationale et on n'entend
absolument partout et même des gros
rappeur qui en mettent dans leur musique
mais c'est surtout le bes le mot belge
guy faut retenir parce que c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup de beille c'est beau
coup de pub c'est une musique où ça
bouge à beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'énergie l'obsède
et pour cette soirée vous allez
accueillir le label never say die qui
fête ses dix ans il a une place
importante soit oui il fait partie des
premiers gros labels dab step donc
justement qui vient de londres et ils
ont signé presque tous les gros noms de
vie sont passés par never die absolument
tous les gros noms je pense composé par
diverses et d'ail et ça reste même
aujourd'hui une référence pour ce qui
est du dubstep
tel est le programme de la soirée alors
on a le la grosse tête d'affiche qui est
son boys
ensuite il ya trente passes pex les 6
bat clac aux prophètes mazda midnight
tyrannosaurus c'est c'est vraiment le
lebel belle équipe de never say die
on retrouve tout programme d'ailleurs
sur le site du vélodrome nationale vous
pourrez vous faire une idée si vous ne
connaissez pas tous ces grands noms
brousse pour se procurer les places on
va sur le site du vélodrome nationale il
ya un lien de redirection à partir de la
page du bureau national et l'avant comme
d'habitude et sur le site de place
minutes qui est la billetterie
officielle est partenaire de l'événement
il commence prépare du côté du vélodrome
à accueillir un tel événement comme
d'habitude très bien parfaitement bien
on met tout en place pour que ce soit
une belle réussite un beau succès et on
n'a aucun doute sur le fait que le
rendez-vous sera excellent et qu'on va
surtout le faire perdurer par la suite
ils ont trait à 42,45 euros c'est ça
c'est les tarifs serrés premier chat à
38 après sa montée à 40,42 ça va aller à
45 pour les derniers milles merci à vous
deux bronzes golstein et salim un ami
d'être venu parler de cette soirée
soirée 100% dubstep pour les 10 ans du
label never say die ça se passe donc
samedi 7 décembre au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et c'est à
partir de 21h avant de vous laisser à la
proche des fêtes les week-ends vont être
animés vous le savez par les
traditionnels marchés noël l'occasion de
trouver pourquoi pas des idées cadeaux
allez that de l'arche d'aigre fois les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
préparent leur marché noël ils
accueilleront le public ce samedi sur le
site de saint rémy les chevreuse manon
varaldo les a rencontrés dans la vallée
de chevreuse 80 personnes avec un
handicap mental vivent et travaillent à
l'arche d'aigrefins créée en 1980 au
sein de cette ancienne ferme fortifiée
les travailleurs handicapés s'activent à
la salle communautaire pour préparer le
marché de noël
nous sommes en train de faire des
couronnes de noël lebon résultat c'est
d'être créatif qui aimait déboule sympa
décorez bambou n'a magali et les autres
sont aiguillés par les bénévoles
elles sont pour certaines présentent
depuis 10 ans grâce aux six bénévoles
l'atelier peut fonctionner l'arche des
greffons accueille 44 interne et 36
externe
ça fait oublier des deux ans que je suis
dans cet établissement et du coup voilà
je suis en stage pendant 16 découvertes
dans l'atelier d'artisanat huit
travailleurs viennent chaque jour de 8
heures à 17 heures pour faire
essentiellement de la couture beaucoup
de produits en développement durable
seront proposées pour le marché de noël
on a des bouillottes qui
il fonctionne très bien puisqu'elles
sont graines de lin bio et elle soulage
les articulations parfois mieux que les
médicaments un peu fort et là par
exemple en couture on vient de lancer un
protège celle en toile enduite pour de
plus d'avoir les fesses mouillé quand on
prend son vélo l'hiver l'activité s'est
diversifiée pour que chacun puisse
maintenir son attention
les travailleurs handicapés ont
confectionné des nouveautés pour les
ventes mari adore la couture mais elle a
une autre passion la dorure en train de
doré décale base qui ont séché qui ont
été produites ici au jardin maraîcher en
objets de décoration pour la période de
noël ou pour soutane et chaque personne
selon sa fragilité sa sensibilité oeuvre
pour ce marché de noël leur confection
sont à retrouver samedi 30 novembre et
dimanche 1er décembre de 10h à 18h à
l'arche des gros points c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi à
suivre ce soir 2 émissions le 7-8
culture et le 7-8 politique
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]